un mismo pedido en otro continente
inspirados en el movimiento que se gestó
en canadá miles de personas conducirán
desde diferentes ciudades francesas
hasta parís con un objetivo exigir la
eliminación de las restricciones
sanitarias por el coi 19 me alegra mucho
venir aquí para tomar parte de este
encuentro y lo más importante alentar a
todos aquellos que se irán en este
convoy de la libertad a aquellos que
tienen el coraje de hacer lo que los
canadienses ya han hecho antes que
nosotros un movimiento que en el
territorio galo ha pedido
específicamente que el gobierno acabe
con el paseo vacunal que determinaba que
sólo las personas que han sido
inoculadas pueden ingresar a lugares
como restaurantes bares cines o museos
watson para que no les falte jing en
contra de los políticos en cada país con
este mandato de vacunas mcshane
ya está mal porque tenemos que
vacunarnos para nada
axiónov en que se espera que miles de
opositores a las medidas sanitarias de
varias latitudes del país converjan en
la capital el viernes por la noche entre
ellos hay trabajadores de la salud
suspendidos por no vacunarse y también
integrantes del movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos que paralizaron
francia en 2019 algunos de los
manifestantes han hablado incluso de
llegar a bruselas pretendiendo generar
un movimiento europeo
el convoy también se ha replicado en
otras latitudes como noa zelanda donde
camiones y caravanas bloquean las calles
frente al parlamento del país